you've heard about anti-aging techniques
for humans but what about dogs
Smithsonian Magazine reveals there's a
new drug closer to approval that could
extend dogs lives uh San Francisco based
startup loyal is developing this
lifespan drug since a dog's average
lifespan is only about 10 to 13 years
the company plans to begin a large scale
clinical trial with 1,000 large dogs in
2024 with the goal of having the product
on the market by 2026 can they hurry up
please my Audrey's like 11 and 1/2 years
old my chihuahua I have her like a
jazzer size anything I can do to keep
her healthy and I look at her and think
can you live forever please I mean
listen and this is like the first um
drug I think the FDA has said we we
would approve this so that's a huge
important factor because it can't get
through otherwise and I think that if it
works in dogs I think they would start
looking at it maybe in human life
expectancy maybe there's something you
could do to make you know that or are
you hypo izing I think I know that no I
read the article they mentioned that
yeah really oh I didn't get that far I
was happy with the dog I was right I was
thrilled with the dogs and I thought oh
me too how great is that throw us a bone
please hello the challenge here though
we're going to have to redo the whole
dog ears to human years math thing it
takes for our dogs to live
longer I am in Roy your story okay um
question is anybody really bugged by
mastication do you know what mastication
is sure do it's chewing it's that chew
the hearing people chew things well the
Washington Post reports Doritos has come
up with a solution making a crunch
silencing app it yeah it's the app you
didn't know you needed really but they
are solving the problem it uses noise
cancelling technology the brand has
created an app called the Dorito silent
that cancels out the sound of chomping
on chips and it it is actually geared
towards people talking over microphones
like Gamers or on a zoom or maybe a
podcaster right so it's a real problem
and the company recorded 5,000 different
types of munching sounds I think I
provided all those munching sounds and
then they mixed in conversation around
the chewing so the AI could pick out
just the munching sound isn't that
fascinating look at this it's it's very
weird my voice sounds completely normal
but behind the scenes it's searching for
the sound of ao's crunch so that it can
remove it from the audio stream let's
give it a
shot I mean
awesome
so okay my first question is why this
yeah right like this is the stupidest
problem that we didn't need solv sorry
if you can't stop shoving food in your
face at work well then you're the
problem you're the problem it's you
you're the problem it's you these yeah
the these Engineers need to solve the
sonic boom problem cuz then I could then
they could cancel that out and I could
go from LA to here let me ask you a
question because everyone talk about AI
we're all kind of scared about what's
coming then we hear oh good it can make
it so you can chew Doritos and nobody
cares great will it do other stuff are
there going to be benefits from all
absolutely like you know big diseases
you know like um you know which ones
like you know there's some potential
with like so my mom passed away from ALS
and there's like a lot of breakthroughs
things like things like that of like
actually figuring out the details of how
these diseases can be solved um okay
Mark Rober his kid stem toy subscription
box crunch Labs is available now
Millions have been sold and millions
more will be sold hopefully with the
help of our show CU we really believe in
what you're doing Mark and stick around
we'll be right
[Music]
back